نبدا بتطورات الموقف في باكستان وننتقل
لمتابعه هذه الصور المباشره الان لحاله
ربما من التوتر نشاهد الشرطه الباكستانيه
الان
تحاول ربما مواجهه او تفريق انصار عمران
خان امام المحكمه في اسلام اباد كانت صور
قد اظهرت القاء الشرطه لقنابل الغاز
والقنابل مسيله للدموع وايضا وزير
الداخليه باكستان كان قد اعلن قبل قليل
العثور على اسلحه في منزل عمران خان
بيلاهور كذلك ايضا في باكستان ايضا غادر
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خانم مدينه
العاصمه اسلام مبادل المثولي امام المحكمه
الابتدائيه الاجتماعي اليه في قضايا فساد
مراسل العربيه كان قد افاد بان الشرطه
الباكستانيه اعتقلت عددا من انصار عمران
خان في اسلام اباد فضلا عن قيام ها بحمله
امنيه على مقر عمران خان في له
ايضا بعض المسؤولين في الحزب السياسي الذي
يتزاعمه رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان صرحوا بان الشرطه دخلت منزله
اثناء مثله امام المحكمه في العاصمه اسلام
اباد هذا الخبر كانت قد نشرته وكاله
رويترز
وقد شهدت الايام القليله الماضيه مواجهه
واشتباكات ايضا عنيفه بين الشرطه وانصار
عمران خان في محيط منزله حيث حاولت الشرطه
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق يوم الثلاثاء
الماضي